how do you direct are you loose when
you're on the set or are you like a real
pain in the ass
well some days i get tense it all
depends on the sun going down or up on
indoors i'm very loose outdoors i'm very
tense is directing a lot of crap like i
mean like could anybody really do it is
acting a lot of crap is acting a lot of
crap can anyone do it it's life a lot of
crap no i i think directing is the
hardest i did all the jobs and directing
a film a movie is the hardest job it is
you want to know the key yeah you see a
movie and after the movie the star was
sensational yeah very easily could have
been the star not the director right you
see a movie and the whole supporting
case is wonderful then it's the
direction and what's with your sister
what's going on with her what's her
story i mean she she when she directs
the film she has to like she shoots and
shoots and shoots for years right penny
and i are both begging directors that's
our style you shoot and shoot and shoot
she's shooting always say please actors
behave do it we're tired we got a
headache we'd like to go home so why
don't we all do it right isn't it true
that you wrote for i love lucy yes isn't
it true i love lucy put you through your
kids through college i love [ __ ]
re-writing you really love losing
yourself here's the story and dick van
dyke too put my kids up you wrote dick
van dyke well gary marshall was you know
hot television writer so all of a sudden
he's in demand he's right and i love
lucy and then he can go right for dick
van dyke so he says hey go right dick
van dyke cause he wants to do a bunch of
stupid lucy you know lucy falling in a
cake yeah i mean i did get cocky that's
true howard yeah
lucy bouncing around physical comedy and
tired of that and yeah somebody pulled
them aside and they said listen don't be
so dopey lucy is going to be on the air
for the next who told you this milt
joseph the producer he says listen gary
you're a good writer you write for lucy
because if you write for lucy you're
going to get checks for the rest of your
life until you drop dead you're going to
get challenged that was a smartphone
that's right i had just done my first
child who wrote the book with me laurie
marshall she was and he said you just
had a kid you needed
writing lucy is like having an insurance
policy and it turned out i wrote lucy in
1965
and still getting still getting checks
how many guys sat and wrote that stuff
we had uh six writers milk joseph was
the head writer really well you sit
around in a room and just write the
script well you pitch it and then you go
home sometimes it's your story idea and
you develop it and then another one
so you would write you would write the
script like at home yourself after you
told them what you were going to go down
yeah with jerry belson we wrote uh you
know like bruce lucy you usually with
lucy you start with the last scene see
nikki and like you gotta get the first
scene lucy would get the lassie lucy
goes to a formal dance and at the
reception line she comes in with a
formal gown she's wearing roller skates
and she slides through and runs which
will be the finale that's the finale now
how do you get it good good idea she'd
like to do that now how do you get it
that's what i did with robin new year's
eve i put her on roller coaster
i never knew what to do with her though
once i got her up on him
across the stage you made me stay out
there almost right off the stage
we used to use you know stories on van
dyck we used a lot of stories from my
life lucy was harder those shows were
brilliant our shows were brilliant
they're a genius i loved it look at you
look at you
oh come on take a bow what's the matter
with you
you